People can be mean.
If only there was a pill that made people
be kinder to one another.
Yep, got that, check.
Hi there everyone, Julian here for DNews.
If you’ve ever been on a little place called
the internet you may have noticed sometimes
it’s a bubbling cauldron of festering impotent
rage.
Sometimes.
Some people just need to take a chill pill,
and now scientists have discovered that a
pill already used to treat parkinsons will
increase someone’s level of chillness.
Scientists from UC Berkeley and UC San Francisco
recently brought in 35 participants and had
half take a placebo and the rest take a drug
called tolcapone.
Tolcapone is already being used to treat parkinsons
by prolonging the effects of dopamine, which
is a hormone and neurotransmitter commonly
associated with pleasure and reward.
Then they had participants play a game where
they divided money between themselves and
a stranger.
At the end of the double blind study the researchers
noticed people on tolcapone tended to divide
the money more fairly than the people who
took the sugar pill.
They concluded that just by increasing dopamine
with a pill we can make people treat each
other better.
And thus all the world’s problems were solved.
Ha, kidding, of course it’s more complex
than that.
First off there’s the problem of possible
side effects.
The thing about dopamine is it’s addictive
as all get out.
Like I said, dopamine is associated with pleasure
and reward.
It’s a big part of what makes Facebook so
addictive.
When you see you got a like or a comment,
your brain rewards you with a little dopamine,
you feel good, and then you’re hooked.
Yes, Mark Zuckerberg is basically the biggest
drug dealer in history
Parkinsons patients sometimes become addicted
to their own medication, or develop new addictive
behaviors like compulsive gambling, shopping,
or hypersexuality.
So taking a drug that keeps dopamine from
being broken down in your prefrontal cortex
can have some gnarly unintended consequences.
There’s also the issue of what this means
for us as human beings.
Should you take a pill that changes your behavior?
There are some instances where I say absolutely
yes.
Particularly with depression, where a common
problem is people don’t want to take their
medication because it feels like “cheating.”
But just to make yourself a little nicer?
It’s a great point to add to the philosophical
discussion on human nature, but I’m not
a philosophy guy.
I’m a science guy.
And I just don’t know.
For more proof chemicals affect your behavior,
check out Laci’s video on hangryness down
here.
Where do you stand on this issue?
Is it ok for people to take a pill to make
them nicer?
Would you do it?
Let us know in the comments or you can find
me on twitter @JHug00, and I’ll see you
next time on DNews.